a Houston man targeted for murder
cheated death by playing dead
Ramon Sosa learned someone was trying to
hire a hitman to kill him that's when he
went to the police for help
Sosa worked with a team of officers to
set up an elaborate sting operation to
discover the suspects surprising
identity 48 hours correspondent Peter
Van Zant gives us a look inside the case
in this week's 48 hours ever think in
your wildest dreams that someone might
want to kill you I would have never
thought that anyone would want to kill
me ever in my life
Ramon Sosa was living the American dream
a successful businessman who rubbed
shoulders with celebrities life was very
sweet he was a doting dad laughter he's
full of energy he's like a life of the
party in 2007 the divorced father of
three found love a second time around
when he met Lulu Dorantes
he's married to a beautiful lady so in
June 2015 it came as a shock when Ramon
got a call from a friend who had
overheard a conversation I remember a
conversation was taking place about
hitmen will come my attention was who's
name came up did they mention Ramon yes
Ramon was stunned to learn who wanted
him dead Lulu and just how serious she
was then he said I seen that look on
people's I before they want to kill
somebody
Lulu had confided to friends she was
going to divorce Ramon after he
allegedly abused her Lulu gave her
divorce attorney julio hablar these
photos Lulu was in fear for her safety
she says they prove Ramon attacked her a
claim he categorically denies and I tell
you sir that his hands have never hit
him a woman and well in their lives
charges were never filed against him to
prove Lulu wanted Ramon killed police
needed his help in an elaborate
undercover sting operation
Ramon would literally have to play dead
yeah we won't take a picture you dead
you know like in a grave police had to
give Ramon an authentic looking bullet
wound we went to YouTube the results no
laughing matter as Ramon went the extra
mile and Six Feet Under
to catch Lulu man we lay down with my
hands behind my back my head turned I'm
the only person alive and has ever
walked out of his own grave Wow Peter
Van Zant is here with us Peter
how did these photos help police make an
arrest the photos were crucial to get
the solicitation of murder
the fake makeup that they had put on it
looked like a gunshot wound they end up
showing to his wife in the back seat of
a car and she's secretly being
videotaped she smiles says I'm gonna pay
you now for the hit so they were crucial
oh my gosh so you've reported on a lot
of crazy stories a lot of crazy this one
in the pantheon well it's really rare
that someone knows they're about to be
murdered or targeted for murder and it's
rarer still that someone sets up their
own sting operation working with a
friend who had some street cred and they
gather enough evidence so police then
come in and finish the job that is quite
extraordinary yeah quite extraordinary
Peter thank you so much thank you and
you can watch Peter's report on 48 hours
tomorrow at 10:00 9:00 central here on
CBS